le geste sûr et avec grande délicatesse
sébastien dépose du bout des doigts de
très fines feuilles d'or on a des
carnets une feuille d'or n'da peu près
25 feuille où on vit dans général
incarné dans l'ordre dans le coussin et
on les reprend une par une pour les
trains de les poser entre 1000 et 1500
fait comme celles ci seront nécessaires
pour recouvrir cette immense pièce du
début du 19e siècle
cette pièce remarquable est un des deux
processions de la cathédrale de chartres
depuis un an sébastien et son équipe ont
la responsabilité de la restaurer là on
a à peu près entouré après 300 heures de
travail dessus la pause la feuille d'or
c'est
la petite cerise sur le gâteau à la fin
mais c'est 70% des bouleaux était fait
avant dans l'atelier de dorures on
travaille en silence et on utilise une
technique bien précises j'ai une pierre
d'agate qui me permette de police a
quadrillé là parce qu'on a des partis
qui sont brillantes et des partis matte
nous placer bruni là c'est matt et ça
c'est boni et ça c'est matt
c'est ce qui nous permet de donner du
relief sébastien et son équipe ne sont
pas à leur premier coup d'éclat le sénat
le domaine national de chambord ou
encore le portail de la préfecture de
tours des clients prestigieux font
régulièrement appel à leurs services
pascal restaure par exemple ce cadre
époque louis 15 de l'abbaye de la
trinité de vendôme à prêteurs depuis 14
ans dans l'atelier il redonne vie à des
objets anciens
à l'aide de sa soeur look chirurgicale
je suis un train de reboucher tous les
ebooks de l'homme carbonate de calcium
avec le col de colvin tout est fait à
base de ça comme dans l'ancien temps
seul d'horreur de la région habilité par
les musées et monuments historiques
sébastien à certains privilèges on va
dans des lieux ou vous vous y est à
jamais donc ça en était le chercher dans
les sous-sols la cathédrale de chartres
à l'endroit où où j'aurais été le simple
visiteur j'aurais jamais eu accès une
fois la dorure terminé il restera encore
la restauration du tissu le des deux
processions pourra ensuite retrouver
début septembre la majestueuse
cathédrale de chartres